joining me right now here on the Rich
Eisen show on the phone Ed talk to me
what's going on in Pittsburgh is is that
Panic Button getting hit by the fan
base the fan base hits the panic button
if they lose one game rich and at three
and three you'd think they were ow and
six you know they Pittsburgh is a city
of bridges there's a lot of them and I
think they have some extra patrols out
lately to make sure nobody's jumping off
of them
so Tomlin did say that he loves those
guys referring to cower and and Hines
Ward but when it all comes down to it uh
he doesn't want to hear this sort of
stuff certainly he would consider that
Friendly Fire yes yeah you know I said
to I saw him mik the other day and I
said to him um I said well you've been
in this spot before and he snapped he
said doesn't mean I want to be here
doesn't mean I like it and uh that's
kind of how they feel you know to Mike
um Mike went on talked to his players
told them in a meeting the other day
they weren't tough enough uh he called a
couple of them out several of them
actually rich uh at his press conference
the other day it's not something he
normally does so I think there's a sense
uh that they're using a word around here
urgency and uh that's how they feel
right now because they coming off 288
Seasons this is not a happy
place well they started slow last year
and had their been a seventh seed in the
playoffs as we're expecting there to be
starting next year they would have made
the playoffs have been a very dangerous
seven seed to boot they're starting slow
again here um that said there does
appear to
be uh a sense of guilty is charged when
it comes to what cower and and Hines
wart are saying about the team would you
agree with that oh definitely on defense
they are soft they they knew that going
in that they were transitioning to what
had been a great defense for a number of
years got helped get them to three Super
Bowls and two Lombardi trophies rich and
um you know they flushed a lot of those
guys out and the irony of it all is they
were they felt they needed so much more
that they called back uh two of the
older guys both 36 years old Brett Kel
and James Harrison uh one at the end of
training camp and the other once the
season started because they need help on
that defense
um as far as the offense they thought
the offense would carry them with the
you know Ben rothberger they have the
leading rusher and Le'Veon Bell in the
AFC Antonio Brown two-time Pro Bowl
receiver who's uh off to his fastest
start and a decent line but they're not
scoring they're moving the ball all over
the place mostly between the 20s they're
not putting it in in the endzone to
carry
them so obviously the finger has been
pointing at Todd Haley for a long time
ever since BR Bruce arens quote unquote
retired on the Steelers Ed and a lot of
folks are are wondering if it's Haley's
offense not suiting Ben rothberger and
that Haley's presence was put there
basically to keep Ben somewhat
uncomfortable based on what was going on
in his off the field issues things have
completely changed apparently in Ben's
personal life and how this is not
working
professionally um is there anything
wrong with what I just said anything
inaccurate if so I'd love to know what's
different because that's what we're
hearing on the national level yeah the
only thing is Rich um last year they got
along and they got off to a terrible
start and then they started putting
things together um in the second half of
the season they went six and two the
offense was a big reason for that Todd
Haley allowed Ben to run the no huddle a
lot more than he's ever run it even
under Bruce arens and things were going
well and then um for the most part this
year they are too until they get near
the goal line and that's I think what uh
Bill Cower was talking about when he
said they have a finesse offense he
meant M mainly when they get down to the
goal line they're not powering it you
know they're not running any power
formations they're uh they're not
getting it getting it in the end zone
they're not a tough-minded team when it
comes down there but other than uh other
than that I don't see any real Schism
between Haley and uh and Ben is but you
know if this stuff continues it'll go
back to the way it was two years ago
when when Todd first came here and those
two did not get along at
all they the 31st in red zone offense Ed
Before I Let You Go what happens when
Monday night football hits and JJ Watt
potentially javian Clowney coming back
gets on that defensive line to go hunt
Ben and or stop le' and Bell from
gashing him what happens do you think
Monday night here in hinfi well the
Steelers are favored and um I you know I
can't pick these things anymore rich in
the
NFL one just when you think you have
your finger on something that goes the
other way in a lot of games but um I
think there you'll see a good
representative Steelers team out there
Monday night especially an offense the
defense I it's going to be a mess for a
long time I think but uh they are going
to make a few changes Personnel changes
on defense uh they're going with the
some young younger guys you might see a
couple more rookies out there and uh you
know we'll see if that helps them at all
but uh the offense is really going to
have to score uh from here on out you
know 30 40 points a game if they're
going to be a playoff
team Ed thanks for joining me here I
appreciate it okay Rich anytime thanks
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
Eastern on
audience